[Musique]
les césar du meilleur espoir masculin et
très attribué à noël thérèse vite qu'à
ya toujours des membres art of dance a
plongé au coeur des luttes peut-être
associations début des années 90 la
veille perez biscayart est né le 6 mars
quatre ans à buenos aires benoît jacquot
a été le premier réalisateur français le
gris g dans le sang des voix à 2010 et
on a aussi dû cette année encore voir
là-haut d'albert dupontel et plus
récemment dans ce qui prenait son père
de johan chemla
on a été un vrai collectif et voilà
qu'on se retrouve à concourir arnaud
quel paradoxe les prix mais bon merci
alors merci
il faut que je pense un peu je partage
ce prix avec tous les gens avec qui j'ai
travaillé
arnaud d'un regard fraternel
bienveillant inspirant c'était super de
jouer avec toi
toutes les actrices les acteurs de ce
film je vous admire tous j'aurais jamais
pu rêver d'un casting aussi formidable
la production les techniciens mariage
hugues merci robin je suis très heureux
de t'avoir rencontré et merci de m'avoir
invité à faire partie de cette aventure
et merci aussi de m'avoir donné de nous
avoir donné autant avec philippe pour
incarner nos personnages dans la liberté
totale
voilà je pense aussi à benoît jacquot
qui a eu la folle idée il ya huit ans
dans un invité un argentin qui parlait
pas français à jouer dans un film
français
merci benoît ça a plutôt bien marché je
pense aussi évidemment albert dupontel
catherine bourgault
merci beaucoup si j'ai eu cette très
belle année c'est évidemment grâce aussi
à au revoir là haut et à toute l'équipe
si je dois didier ce petit c'est acte et
à tous ceux et celles qui mènent des
combats aujourd'hui qu'ils reçoivent pas
de prix qui ne sont pas reconnus pour
leur lutte par exemple en argentine en
ce moment les femmes se battent pour que
l'avortement soit enfin légal donc voilà
je suis sûr que dans le futur
les indifférents et même les gens qui
nous sont hostiles se rend ce rendez
vous remercier voilà merci à l'académie
merci à tous pour ce soutien et à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]